lorsque je monte sur scène j'ai
l'impression que je deviens Amadou
impact débat celui-là qui disait que le
compte est un miroir où chacun peut voir
sa propre image
lorsque je monte sur scène sans mes
chaussures je deviens Brenda facile la
madone des tanji celle qui se bat pour
que les enfants de la rue puissent
manger lorsque je monte sur scène je
deviens Kim pas Vita Béatrice la
prophétesse du royaume Congo et parfois
lorsque j'oublie de monter sur scène je
deviens
les magnifiques montagnes qui nous
racontent leurs histoires ici en Guinée
Conakry parce que ce qui est beau en
Afrique c'est que l'Afrique se raconte à
travers des générations mais ce qui est
triste c'est qu'aujourd'hui que vous
soyez compteur artiste
personne ne ressource maman
on a tous le même défi raconter notre
histoire mais à qui raconter cette
histoire alors aujourd'hui je voudrais
vous parler d'un enfant c'est donc à cet
enfant qu'il faut raconter l'histoire
je vais vous proposer un petit exercice
parce que pour que vous puissiez
visualiser à quoi ressemble ce enfant il
va falloir que vous fermiez les yeux
seulement je vous promets que nous
allons revenir ensemble dans cette salle
et à tout moment lorsque vous vous
sentez à l'aise d'ouvrir les yeux
faites-le c'est pas un jeu où on gagne
ou un jeu où on gagne aussi
alors le jeu
ah oui
elle a compris elle elle a vu l'enfant
avant même que l'enfant ne se manifeste
alors je vais vous dire talio talio qui
est un peu une manière de dire c'est
l'heure de l'histoire
et pour que vous puissiez rester
concentré lorsque vous entendez talio
faudra fermer les yeux
et lorsque je dirais t'alater faudra
ouvrir les yeux
l'exercice il est très important parce
qu'en fait c'est ici que le voyage
commence ici et maintenant lorsque vous
fermez les yeux vous allez m'accompagner
dans ce voyage à la découverte de cet
enfant
ça vous tente
si ça vous tente
et vous là-bas ça vous tente
talio
6 ans
maman pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit partir
pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit voyager c'est
beau notre pays
oh tu sais mon enfant il faut qu'on
parte parce que ton père a eu un boulot
oui mais ici aussi il peut faire le même
travail ici aussi ils ont besoin de
médecins mais s'il part qui va soigner
les autres mais papa n'est pas comme les
autres médecins d'ici il faut qu'il
reste
à 6 ans cet enfant quitte la Guinée
Conakry pour aller s'installer dans un
pays complètement différent la Guinée
équatoriale dans un pays où pour la
première fois elle découvre la
différence
manger à la main pendant que les autres
enfants du quartier se moquent parce
qu'ils n'ont jamais vu des gens manger
avec les mains mais c'est qui eux ces
animaux pourquoi ils mangent avec les
mains venez voir tous les enfants se
moquaient
parce que cette petite fille mangez avec
les mains tu as la tête
continue à suivre l'enfant talio
7 ans
elle porte une robe jaune
avec des
élastiques de couleur
elle fait la file
ça va faire bientôt 4 heures qu'elle
attend à ce qu'il paraît dans ce
quartier chaque année
les organisations comme les
organisations ceux-là qui viennent
donner des cadeaux aux enfants
elle attendait son tour pour elle aussi
recevoir un cadeau
à la maison on l'attendait pour qu'elle
vienne présenter ce cadeau ça faisait 4h
qu'elle attendait
4h après toutes les boîtes sont vides
des vingtaines de boîtes toutes vides
alors la petite fille de sa petite
taille avec ses petites sandales jaunes
et sa robe jaune se met à fouiller dans
chaque boîte
aucun cadeau et de boîte en boîte elle
garde l'espoir parce qu'à la maison
avant qu'elle ne parte sa mère lui a dit
que Dieu te bénisse elle y croit elle
c'est sa mère qui l'a dit mais pourtant
est-ce que ça voulait dire que elle due
à oublier de la bénir parce qu'elle
n'avait pas trouvé de cadeaux et à la
dernière boîte elle se tenait devant une
femme
d'un certain âge qu'il a pu voir dans
ses yeux le cœur brisé d'un enfant qui
croit qui ne mérite pas d'un enfant qui
finalement pense que lui n'a pas reçu la
bénédiction de Dieu
parce que toutes les boîtes étaient
vides alors la femme dit à l'enfant mais
c'est pas grave si vous n'avez pas eu de
cadeau aujourd'hui c'est vous le cadeau
l'enfant triste parce qu'elle ne
comprend pas ce que l'adulte dit
retourne à la maison les mains vides
mais pourquoi tu pleures
ce n'est rien je ne pleure pas alors à
cet âge cette petite fille avait
l'habitude de voir sa mère pleurer
sa mère pleurer l'absence d'un pays et
pourtant là où il vivait c'était beau
aussi sa mère pleurait
d'absence d'histoire et pourtant dans ce
pays il y avait quand même des choses à
raconter sa mère pleurait la famille et
pourtant dans ce nouveau pays ils
avaient formé leur propre famille alors
sa mère pleurait tout dernier étage
coloré qui n'avait pas pu se déplacer
avec eux que par de la musique de la
macédé alors sa mère pleurait tout ça et
cet enfant à cet âge quand on voit un
parent pleurer qu'est-ce que un enfant
pourrait bien dire à cette mère alors
dans cette histoire cette petite fille a
eu l'inspiration de lui dire n'est née
est-ce que tu pleures parce que tu n'es
pas heureuse tu sais j'irai à la
poursuite mais avant j'irai à la
recherche du bonheur est-ce que le
bonheur se trouve dans ton pays là de là
d'où nous sommes nous avons quitté
ce que vous savez les enfants ils
cherchent un peu leur les mots c'est
comme ça c'est des enfants mais ils
parlent avec le cœur c'est comme ça ce
sont des enfants mais j'irai à la
recherche du bonheur et je te promets
que je vais te le ramener toi qui écoute
rien alors tu seras le coudre un boubou
un boubou d'avenir comme ça le bonheur
ne te quittera plus ce sont les mots
d'enfants
restez ici avec moi si certains d'entre
vous ont réussi à percevoir l'enfant si
certains d'entre vous ont réussi à se
reconnaître à travers
certaines scènes à travers l'émotion
c'est que vous avez encore votre enfant
intérieur qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
dans cette salle je vois des adultes
nous avons un point commun c'est que
nous avons tous déjà été enfant un jour
dans notre vie mais seulement dans
certains pays en contexte de
vulnérabilité les adultes sont
occupés préoccupés ils n'ont plus le
temps pour payer le loyer
la vie va vite faut chercher un travail
pour aller à l'école il y en a qui n'ont
même pas de maison la seule chose qu'ils
espèrent c'est est-ce que je vais me
réveiller demain matin seulement ces
adultes là ont été pour certains des
enfants blessés oubliés des enfants
abattus des enfants qui n'ont même pas
connu le bonheur mais ses enfants sont
devenus aujourd'hui des adultes révenons
sur la thématique que Dieu vous business
pourquoi ce thème
et vous démocratie
ce thème aurait pu s'appeler autrement
mais pourquoi que Dieu vous bénisse
après 20 ans je suis revenue à la maison
après 20 ans j'ai eu le privilège de
rencontrer ma grand-mère et de connaître
c'est que d'avoir une grand-mère après
20 ans j'ai pu découvrir à quel point la
langue maternelle de mes parents étaient
romantiques après 20 ans j'ai pu dire
nénébreux
laisse-moi travailler un peu quand je
finis je vais venir nous allons compter
des histoires parce qu'en fait durant
tout mon séjour au village je passais
mon temps sur l'ordinateur
à créer des outils parce que c'est ce
que je fais dans ma fonction d'art
thérapeute créer des outils pour le
renforcement des capacités des leaders
créer des outils pour que des directeurs
puissent inspirer par leur forme de
leadership par des outils artistiques
créer des outils pour que des
organisations puissent mettre en place
des leviers de mobilisation collective
pour accompagner les communautés tout ça
par l'art seulement le village un
ordinateur une grand-mère qui ne
comprend pas quand elle s'approche elle
me dit et mbay il a déjà
assises toute la journée tu assises tu
joues tu joues et je lui dis nimbero je
suis pas en train de jouer je travaille
je fais des business
je travaille elle me dit dessiner
business ça veut dire quoi et vous savez
elle arrivait pas à prononcer le Nest
qui qui lui rappelait un peu Nassi Nassi
en foulard ça veut dire filtre les
filtres médicinales à travers lesquels
quand on
vous lave vous avez l'impression que
vous pouvez rebondir de n'importe quel
situation alors elle m'a dit non on
utilise plus ça Dieu t'a béni
Dieu
a fait de toi celle que tu es
aujourd'hui à ta naissance nous avons
fait des prières
vous êtes partis mais vous n'avez pas
oublié de vous venez tu es revenu au
rouge aujourd'hui et tu peux encore
parler d'Allah
Dieu t'a forgé des épreuves Dieu ne t'a
pas oublié
porte tes chaussures petite paresseuse
viens je vais t'apprendre à s'aimer les
arachides tu vas voir que c'est beaucoup
mieux que ton business
finalement j'accompagne ma grand-mère
dans ce processus
s'aimer des arachides quel exercice je
vous le souhaite parce que si vous avez
un projet dans la vie quel que soit le
projet
si vous l'imaginez comme ce processus de
s'aimer et d'attendre la récolte c'est
ce que ma grand-mère m'a fait vivre et
j'ai compris que il y a quelque chose
dans l'art qui nécessite d'être mis en
pratique il y a quelque chose dans l'art
dans une Afrique où les artistes sont
oubliés dans une Afrique où les artistes
pourraient être je dis bien et je pèse
mes mots de d'excellents politiciens
car les artistes ont eux une façon de
voir le monde et quand ce monde est
triste devinez quoi ils peuvent le
colorier les artistes sont ses crayons
de couleur qui m'aiment brisés peuvent
continuer à colorier ces artistes là ont
cette capacité
de façonner mais des artistes vous avez
tous une arme d'artistes car à chaque
fois que vous perdez l'espoir en quelque
chose et que vous dites
c'est la volonté de Dieu quelque part
votre subconscient réfléchit à des
possibilités à des pistes de solutions
et très souvent ça se passe dans
l'observation c'est ce qui fait chaque
Africain à une âme d'artiste finalement
je dirais chaque humain grand âge a une
âme d'artiste et ma grand-mère en a eu
une et lorsque j'ai quitté le village
Elma appelée elle m'a dit à l'oreille
petite paresseuse que Dieu te bénisse
[Applaudissements]